بعدما وصفه بالجيد بشكل مخيف اله ماسك
ينقلب على الذكاء الاصطناعي شات ويطالب
بوقف تطويره لانه يشكل خطر كبير على
المجتمعات كلام ماسك جاء عبر رساله مفتوحه
وقع عليها اكثر من الف شخص دعوا فيها الى
التوقف لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه اقوى
من روبوت الدردشه
الذي اطلقته شركه اوبن ال في الاونه
الاخيره رساله ماسك الصادره عن معهد
طرحت عده اسئله ابرز هذه الاسئله هل يجب
ان نسمح للالات باغراق قنواتنا الاعلاميه
بالدعايه والكذب هل ينبغي ان نطور عقولا
غير بشريه قد تفوقنا عددا وذكاء وتتفوق
علينا وتحل محلنا وتقول ايضا الرساله
الموجهه لتشات انه لا يجب تفويض قرارات
كهذه لقاده تكنولوجيا غير منتخبين والتاكد
من ان اثار هذه القرارات ستكون ايجابيه
وان مخاطرها ستكون تحت السيطره وهنا لابد
من الاشاره مشاهدينا بان ماسك هو من مؤسسي
شركات
الرائده وشركه تسلا للسيارات تستخدم كما
هو معروف ومعلوم الذكاء الصناعي في انظمه
القياده الذاتيه
روبوت الدردشه
اثار مخاوف المشرعين الامريكيين ايضا
وتساءلوا عن تاثيره على الامن القومي
والتعليم والحكومه البريطانيه هنا كشفت
النقاب عن مقترحات لوضع اطار تنظيم قابل
للتكيف حول الذكاء الصناعي الشركه الام
اليتشات لم تعلق على كافه المخاوف
والتساؤلات متسلحه طبعا بالنجاح الذي
حققته بفتره قصيره بعدما وصل عدد
المستخدمين لتطبيق 100 مليون مستخدم نشط
شهريا
[موسيقى]